you know i'm nobody no it's just my
opinion but i don't even think what's
the purpose of living if you're not
going to have children
right and that's your time machine your
kids are your time machine
you have kids no i'm actually well i'm
about to have a baby girl do you
but i'm 34.
i shoot blanks dude i don't know dude i
don't got that
i don't got daddy ruiz i think it's the
position
well what position your life
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hot boxing with mike tyson i
am your co-host triple c
aka henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson
our guest here today former heavyweight
champion of the world
introduce our champion for us and that
is the former heavyweight champion of
the world andy reid let's get him let's
give him a round of applause ladies and
gentlemen
thank you thank you thanks for having me
again
you got to tell us about your last fight
brother that was struggling
i was it was a really good fight man i
was actually
um i didn't think chris arrila was gonna
come out like that he did his thing
but you know i had to overcome that was
exciting
though yeah that was exciting man
anthony man when you got up and came
back and um
that was just a good fight man i know
the people that their monies were
yeah there's a lot of different switches
when
when someone drops you it's hard to
overcome that
and come out to did a good job though
yeah
thank you yeah you did a good job those
combinations you do those combinations
combinations picked it up you know you
know you know what really impressed me
in that fight with uh with with chris in
the third round
he when he when he dropped he dude and
then he hurt you a second time but the
second time that he hit you you stayed
up
oh yeah you know what i'm saying you're
like [ __ ] that you ain't dropping me a
second time right now
candy you if you were the man you're the
man
thank you man as after the long layoff
um
when i lost against anthony joshua's i
kind of felt to
you know in the ring i felt the
rustiness i felt
it was just so just much different than
sparring and fighting in a real fight
but you know i got the rounds in um i
got the job done that's the most
important thing
you hit listen yeah your comic fight was
amazing
you shouldn't even feel bad about that
don't let that your mind play tricks and
you did a great job
okay yeah people don't understand too
the fact that you guys are bigger men
going 12 rounds dude you know what i'm
saying
well they'll understand it's what it
takes to get in the ring
yeah but i'm glad thank god everything
worked out good and you know
gotta move on and got to stay busy
before
i wouldn't be training like how i am now
before i would fight boom
start doing everything what are you
having everything you want to fight next
brother um you know there's a lot of
different options there's luiz ortiz
that's been calling me out
there's white from from the uk
there's there's a lot of there's a lot
of good opponents out there and
you know um i just gotta stay in shape
and be ready
mike mike do you think do you think uh
the heavyweight from your
era you think now cause heavyweight
heavyweights for a minute there was a
drought in popularity
back in the back when you're boxing do
you think it's gone back mike to the
glory days the heavyweight division
well it has a lot of guys like um andy
you know i have a lot of exciting guys
in the division
yeah and yeah i think it's very exciting
you think about him and fighting he
could he could fight with that
brother named um dante wilde
yeah you could you got so many guys to
fight you could fight that guy from
england again
with the black guy white um tyson fury
but another guy too for me was this
black guy
you're just stealing white yeah yeah
that's the guy that's
me and him actually been going back and
forth talking [ __ ]
to each other but he has no respect bro
yeah it'll be a good fight between me
and him
um louise ortiz as well wilder i thought
me and me and waldo were going to
negotiate something but
i guess won the claws to for the
trilogy for tyson fury so then he's
mandatory now i mean
deontay wilder has to fight tyson fury
three
in order for in order for him to fight
anthony joshua yeah
and it's crazy because listen joshua
didn't get paid no side money
let them fight but they just took the
fight away from him
i don't think they told them that
they're suing them or anything like that
but you you want to share them
how do you take the fight away too
i think because they already had a
contract
yeah so then that has to take place man
so what what's
how would you like to see the because
you guys are the fourth horseman man
joshua you tyson fury and deontay
wilderman
dude that's a freaking that's a bracket
of a bracket i think they should have
like a tournament where we all
get to fight each other and to see who's
like but dante
dante and um tyson they're making that
loot man yeah that's gonna be a really
good fight they're making that money
that's if they fight what do you think
what do you think uh mike
who would take that or it goes either
way
no way um you know
dante wilder has nothing to be sad about
there's nothing to complain
for a great fight you know i just think
tyson might got his number
anything to happen because he punches
hard do you think size matters in that
fight mike
well they're both the same size pretty
much right in different ways
different ways heavier right yeah tyson
ferries got him by like i think 30
pounds man
right 30 40 pounds it was like at 270
something and
um wilder was like at 220 something to
30.
how much how much was he again what was
what was the pound difference
probably 50 pounds i think if tyson fury
um pressures him and brings the fight to
him i think we would see the same thing
as the last fight
that appeared to happen but the people
the people want to see it the people
want to see it you know i even messaged
eddie hearns and i told him hey
eddie what's up with the trilogy against
me and anthony joshua
and the only thing he wrote was like um
the worried um faces and deja vu
and i think that would be it would be
perfect well you just
said texture you could text the
promoters and stuff i always
what's that about texting the promoter
that was always the enemy
but [ __ ] you
now we have to approach it the different
ways
yeah yeah i learned that now yeah and
it's like come on lady herons [ __ ]
give me the fight and
yeah so what ended up happening because
i know you obviously you
you gave joshua the opportunity how come
how come your claws didn't work
how it worked with that with joshua and
uh because it wasn't the same i don't
think we signed for
um for a rematch clause or something or
something that we could you guys know
one or two you guys just kind of like
missed i mean
i think on the contract they say that we
couldn't or something i had to win
had to win that fight but yeah but
weren't you the a side since you had all
the belts at that time when you beat him
you're the ace side
right yeah but made a mistake you know
what
it's happening for a reason but more
opportunities will come long as we
stay active we stay busy and we stay in
the
ahead of the game you know do you think
joshua will give you that that third
fight man you think deep down yeah i'm
pretty sure they will
unless they're out of respect i'm scared
yeah no but i'm talking about joshua
like joshua the
fighter the person will he give you that
that that trilogy
what do you think i don't know i think i
think anthony joshua respects you a lot
man because even the second fight
he still sees that she could have came
back and you could have knocked his ass
out again
for a real thing i think i think you're
the last person he would want to fight
because you're [ __ ] super dangerous
dude
and he's not used to a body style like
he's somebody that goes high low low
high
and you know what i'm saying no anthony
give me the chance
i mean because that's money dude those
those are pay days those those are pay
days that are
life-changing and this sucks because
yeah but you're going to say
a lot of guys out there for you to fight
man you look good last fight i got off
the feet of the flank
um chris was up for the fight he was
up and he was you know you you fighting
you throwing those combinations
yeah okay you gotta move a little bit
more i kind of got confident in the
first few rounds i think that's how
he kind of got me in the back of my head
and kind of wobbled me a little bit
but that's the thing about fighters when
they
get dropped they have to come back
stronger you know well you were
professional you did that
you make a big thing you went down you
got back up and you started throwing
punches
you know don't make anybody make feel
like you did something bad in your punk
and you went down there yeah
don't do that everybody talks don't let
these people in your [ __ ] head they
ain't in the [ __ ] ringy
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know if they're
in the ring the guy don't even have to
you wouldn't even have to hit me just
walk around the circle till they drop
dead of a heart attack
you know they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about tell them they're
getting them
oh they have a [ __ ] heart attack
man you can imagine somebody you ain't
never fought this guy never did not to
this guy before never seen him before
and he wants to kill you
they never experienced that
those guys haven't experienced that to
talk that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] want to kill you for
nothing to nothing to this guy he just
wants to kill you
i mean that crazy mental yeah
that's something tally has to be because
at the end of the day they're trying to
do the same for you
yeah exactly and each of both of you
know if i win this fight
i move up more my family do better the
higher the more i win
the better my family comes about you
know that's how we all think
look no one's perfect even the best
baseball players strike
out with bases loaded the best golfers
sometimes
three putt but the tournament on the
line so if you feel you come up
short in the bedroom sometimes it's
perfectly okay but if it's bothering you
there are options
go to getroman.com hotboxing
now with roman you can get a free online
evaluation on
ongoing care of ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your home
a us licensed health care professional
will work with you
to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate
it will be shipped to you free with a
two-day shipping the whole process is
straightforward
and discreet getting started is simple
just go to getroman.com
hotboxing and complete an online visit
take care of your ed without leaving
home go to getroman.com
now and get 15 off your first month look
there's a straightforward way to take
care of your ed get roman.com
hot boxing get started now and save 15
bucks on your first month of treatment
so andy man how much because i think
when i when i think when i think of your
story man i think of like a dude that uh
that nobody knew you're always really
good always great but never had the
opportunity
until the the heavy weight that was
supposed to fight joshua pulled out
and then you came in as a short notice
after after beating anthony
anthony joshua how much has your life
changed it changed a lot you know when i
won
and made history not just for me but for
my loved ones and my family my kids
but mexican race yeah until
i i kind of went crazy you know i kind
of went crazy and didn't do the things
that i was supposed to do
i wasn't disciplined i didn't listen to
my corners or
to my family at some point because
at that time i was i waited like 28
years for me to
to make my dreams come true and i wish i
could take it all back and boom i would
have been
still back in the gym and would have
been ready for
for joshua um in my second fight but
the time went by so fast man and listen
you're nothing's over you're still a
young baby and it's not over
i know but i keep that i keep that
inside of me
and because i don't want i don't want
that to happen again
well listen just keep on fighting with
the belief system you have
and keep on being confident come on man
that's just one for you i know you're
letting a little fight like that last
fight with joshua discourage you
no of course you're former heavyweight
champion of the world you can get the
title back and you have many
opportunities
never feel sorry for yourself you have a
great position in life
yeah so right now i feel the the main
thing is just to
stay busy and stay that's what's all
about staying active
i have 15 fights in one year they have
15 fights
one year yeah that's a lot 15
15 ko's too did anybody go past the
first round like
one guy
[Laughter]
that's a good ratio back in those days
it was crazy man
you could do that [ __ ] fight all the
time did you grow up watching a lot of
mike's mike's arabs like boxing
how are you guys i'm 31 years old okay
yeah yeah
okay of course we'll watch him and um
it was just scary too you know the
knockouts yeah
[Laughter]
i'm gonna eat you i'm gonna eat your
kids
[Laughter]
i don't know what i would what i would
say if somebody told me
how would a third fight with you when
anthony joshua would be different
i think it would be a lot different
because you've seen what i could do
and with me being out of shape me being
i'm almost 300 pounds and me being in
shape
me being ready like just how i was in my
first fight against him i think
i would win man yeah that for sure i
would feel that i would win
i'm learning a lot of stuff right there
with eddie and canelo so
i think um i think my style will be a
little bit different than
the first time what advice would you
have for that mike going into the third
fight with somebody would you think
would be the difference in that fight
well i think the jab his jab
basically put him in position for
everything i think he
has to keep using the jab putting it in
the face two or three times
follow with the right left you know well
without the jab you can't
really throw no combination especially
with these big guys we have to throw the
jabs to get in there you know yeah yeah
because you're you're considered
like you don't know if you don't throw a
jab he can see everything coming
you see the hooks you can see everything
coming you got blind keep
doing that behind them yeah but he's a
lot because you're you're what six six
foot
eight i mean six one six one yeah
but for like the heavyweights with the
tyson you know i mean these dudes are
what six seven dude but sometimes that's
that could be a disadvantage yeah
for me i liked fighting taller fighters
because for some reason it's
easier for me to get in there um see the
punches he saw what happened in the
first fight when he fought joshua joshua
was
for real cautious the second fight i
guess i'll point at him tap
tap boom yeah yeah yeah he thought you
had distance
but i was too big and without the
condition to
cut the rings to to follow him you know
not to follow him but to cut the rings
and to throw the combinations right
there i was just doing
one punch two punch and there's some
punches that would
connect them and like wobble him but i
feel i didn't have the stamina to
continue to keep throwing or i don't
know but things happen
but you guys throw those combinations
like you're doing your last but you know
you still come they were good they kept
them from throwing back at you
yeah and look good good combination sets
you got to keep working because i did
felt the rest from
being like almost two years off but like
how you're saying stop beating yourself
up that was beautiful man two years
that was beautiful super technical and
like chris aragolo he's
i mean he was huge he's so down he got
i can remember when you know when i was
your you coming back from a knockdown
people was like wow
that was great you know i mean don't be
feeling down for that most people get
discouraged get knocked down
cover up and let you stop them and stuff
yeah just that that
shows you fighting spirit that shows
your focus and your will right
fight yeah you're you're focused but
you're you're almost like you got it
that's that mexican in you man you grew
up watching a lot of uh
uh yeah of course
when morales yeah
marcus it's a blessing to be in their
positions how they were as well you know
because i
didn't really think that i was gonna
become
the first mexican heavyweight champion
because everybody would doubt me because
i was chubby and no
nobody believed now that chubby kid's
gonna get knocked out by this big guy
and i don't know for some reason i
wasn't
i wasn't scared of nothing that's what
my dad's gonna do it again man
yeah we're going to do it again my dad
would tell me here
um that i wasn't scared of nothing when
i was a little kid
because i was always this chubby kid
that nobody was in my weight class
so i had to fight these older guys and
and there some of them were men and i
was only like 13 years old and i would
beat them up
but that's a good experience when you
young kids from guys you fight you have
to fight their father the father
did you have to beat us some dads andy
it's crazy man but a good experience
that i had when i was young and
trying to go to the olympics as well
didn't happen
but how was your amateur career for
those who don't know your uh
your records because man i feel like as
much as professionals you know
the tar i feel like in my eyes like the
purest and the hardest
and all of boxing is amateur boxing it's
a trip
because it's hard because three minutes
to three three minute rounds to do a lot
of stuff
yeah they favor a lot of in the amateurs
you know especially
in boxes you're all a favorite too oh
you're like that much yeah movers get
all the flavor to them
really did you feel like you got cheated
before two months
big time oh yeah i dropped the guy and
then he dropped him twice
he still went jesus yeah
what the hell how many fights did you
have in the amateurs mike
about 50. 50.
what about you andy i had like 120.
okay 120 i started at six years old and
i had my first amateur fight i was seven
years old
and from there on i kept kept fighting
you mean listen you mean guys and
averages some of these russians some of
these european they have 400 fights 500
fights
yeah all their life they've been
fighting they can turn professionals so
they've been fighting all their life
you know that's crazy was that one of
your first dreams to go to the olympics
before it was shows because there's
never been a
heavy mexican to go to the olympics from
mexico so
i was really close i lost against a
brazilian guy
i forgot his name too but he's a pro he
fought dylan white as well
just like you said you forgot this name
you all forgot this name yeah but we
know who you are
no i know i'm not making fun of nobody
no you're for sure
i said what's his name yeah what's his
name
yeah hey we came for the world brother
just remember those things don't look
don't ever feel bad on yourself
be down on yourself which what's your
predictions with the wilder of
uh fury now it's it's gonna go down and
i don't think there's there's a reason
why they should take it a court again
this is this is what it is i don't know
i feel every man that's 200 and
something pound is dangerous you know
because it only takes one punch to
change the whole fight and
um you know wilder's dangerous i think
tyson fury
if he does the same thing that he did in
his last fight
um i think he could take it yeah i want
to see him fight those guys tyson
i would want to fight jackson perry i
think it would be
my style would be a really good for for
him i think
he i would make him happy he's gonna jab
a lot
i think you're problematic for for
anybody especially
everybody knows gonna be excited he's
fighting the only all three of those
guys joshua
um dante uh tyson yeah i think even
though i think even though you uh the
second fight did go to joshua
i think i think you're still the most
dangerous heavyweight right now
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah as
long as we stay busy
and speed this christmas heads because
they're
just fascinating they're coming out yes
because they can't even throw back after
you go
yeah that was a really good fight man
yeah he came to fight
man he came to yeah
i know he was mad after the fight as
well
what's your take on everything that's
going on right now with uh with like
youtube boxing man and these uh
these youtubers trying to take over the
game these tick tockers
they bring a lot of money to the game
yeah that's crazy but
you know there's there's entertainment
you know i saw dante while the
[ __ ] some youtuber up he came to the gym
he talked about
dante dr white went to the gym and beat
his [ __ ]
ass i thought oh [ __ ] he could really do
that without getting arrested
that i would have been arrested
and it's crazy that that that kid he uh
that guy he put on the gloves he he
wanted to huh
yeah but they started swinging he said
oh [ __ ] let me get out of there
oh so he actually i don't know about
this you can't pull that up man yeah
while the boxing tick tock oh you guys
say oh [ __ ]
see i like it you see typically mike's
the one that caused the the video roll
you know what i'm saying
though that guy's brave
dante wilder's a crazy [ __ ]
remember this [ __ ] oh this guy's so
crazy right yeah this shiver would
always talk [ __ ] so
yeah tell me tell me about it you
talking about it
[Applause]
oh
and this [ __ ] wasn't organized
he could go to jail for this [ __ ] look
at that
that kid is still there
man for this [ __ ]
damn i would be so
underneath the prison from doing this
[ __ ] man
maybe the youtuber didn't want to
follow he's and he's still gonna fight
you see and he's still down something's
wrong with that guy
[Laughter]
and he's still calling him out yeah
my youtuber was disrespectful because he
would always go to the gym he would be
messaging him oh yeah
dumb stuff um oh he glad he missed that
one when he was on the floor right now
he's happy that man missed that uppercut
god
damn
but that's pretty i mean at least he
didn't pull you know he didn't press
charge or anything like that i mean he
put the gloves
on fire like the steak press charges on
you
oh man yeah he really pissed off deontay
bro i thought that uppercut he's looking
mr
uppercut baby this could have been
damn it was a
dangerous situation yeah so what do you
think about the youtubers
i think it's all entertainment you know
i don't want to
talk bad or talk [ __ ] about it
yeah [ __ ] like that
[Laughter]
but at the end of the day we're all
risking our lives in there you know even
if they don't know
really how to throw punches or nothing
like that at least they have the balls
to go in there and
get in the ring and fight each other but
do you think that's good do you think
that's good for the sport man or
i don't think it's it's gonna help it or
anything like that but
you know um or maybe it will you never
know because there's gonna be a lot of
different youtubers that are gonna be
watching more
more interested in boxing and jake paul
brought 75 million views
to the fight when he did with us like
that
and he's doing he's he's getting better
and better man jake paul i thought he's
getting better and better
do you think you can beat uh do you keep
up with mma um a little bit yeah do you
think he'll
you think he could be tyrone woodley in
a boxing match yeah
i don't know i need to see um his fights
the other guy yes so is the is the dm
uh from eddie herm true man yeah i
messaged him and i told him
uh but for what fight the first one or
or the recent one
i said well i imagine i imagine the
recent one
well he's just saying that he's picking
um
that is just not using that's gonna be
the the front runner there's
several people that are how about some
european guys
like didn't white no i'm talking about
didn't the guy knock him out with an
uppercut profession
and provok the book here yeah him with
the uppercut
beautiful i was actually so happy
because i'm not a really big fan of
dylan white because he i feel he doesn't
respect no fighters so
i was just really happy when profession
got him with the uppercut
i have respect i have respect after we
joined this [ __ ] for respect
but he did his job in the second fight
dylan white didn't
he fought him again yeah and beat him
mm-hmm
well he was already winning them in the
hockey the first fight
yeah but things happen what do you what
do you think is your hardest match if
you were to fight
who you think would be your hardest
matchup man in the heavyweight division
i don't know i feel all fights are going
to be tough yeah
like you say everyone has a plan until
they get hit and
but i don't know i would really want me
and tyson fury to fight i think that
would be
a really good fight i know he has his
things that he has to fight
i don't like to see that one too mm-hmm
me too
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
guys out there louis ortiz just
yeah i'm thinking about that too i've
been with him too he just called me out
i posted something on instagram a little
durable yeah
yes but i feel well with the pressure um
standing close throwing combinations um
i think we could definitely get that win
but it's all up to
our promoters and and all that to me
yeah move your head as soon as you punch
because you got punched back
mm-hmm yeah or ortiz he he ortiz is an
olympic champion right
he's he's a kid he's a little bit
olympics before he won the olympics
before but he's not
cubans did he win gold i'm not sure
maybe it's filled with something
but our cubans are our favorite for the
olympics
when i was trying to fight for the
olympics i lost against the cuban too
but they favored them so much and
they've got the system down pat
like guys like us right we train
to be this to be professional fighters
those guys train to be
the amazon all their career they're
never gonna be professionals
and they got that system down pat where
they got a point
you could drop them twice and they can
go pop pop pop
that one point ahead of you ain't that
something i dropped him twice so he goes
pop pop now he's even poked by the heads
yeah and the amateurs are different we
lose a lot of ambulances you're coming
to pros you're beating everybody
you know it's just a weird system
different system
different system uh andyman what what
other what are the what are the projects
you have coming up i see you're
sponsored by uh carritos
you're in commercials now um yeah for
sweater x
is like a a mexican brand pedialyte
but it's for for mexico and um we're
just investing investing the money
buying lots right now we're on the verge
of uh
finishing the 26 houses uh that means
you don't pay real estate
god's not making any more of that real
estate
yeah as much as you can so you're in
real estate
well thanks to my dad and the people
around me they're helping me out a lot
and
you know because boxing is not forever
you know you have to pressure your money
and
some guy told me his name is mr monday
and he told me
rule number one is don't lose what you
got and
no just to be smart and and the first
times i was buying dumb stuff
i feel like anybody would but you know
we i have five kids so i gotta look for
their future and my future as well
but as long as i keep listening to to
the
older guys that know how to invest the
money and know how to manage the money
then i'm
sure we're gonna be good you know when i
when i didn't have it
i wanted it so bad now that i have it i
don't want it anymore
that's how i feel with all the cars that
i have the toys and stuff
yeah you can't drive them because
there's no gas
in them because there's too many cars
being driven you know
tell me about you tell me about your
kids man five kids bro
god leave it yeah i was gonna shoot
blanks dude
no i was actually gonna bring my son he
was with me everywhere he goes with me
everywhere
he was there at the fights as well he's
a
character kid man he's crazy not shy of
anything
he'll go up to like hey what's up like
what is that or
he's he's really he's amazing you know
i'm nobody you know just my opinion but
i don't even think what's the purpose of
living you're not gonna have children
right yeah and that's your time machine
your kids are your time machine you have
kids no i'm actually
well i'm about to have a baby girl but
i'm 30 40. so i'm saying
mexican bar you need to catch up we need
to catch her
i shoot blanks dude i don't know did i i
don't got that
i don't got daddy louise
a lot of that a lot of your motivation
that comes from your family yeah
of course my kids my my dad's always
been there
even me and him we love each other we
hate each other but he
at the end of the day he's always right
there behind me telling me
what i should be doing you know even if
i don't want to hear he still tells me
if i'm [ __ ] up or if i'm not doing
this right and
it's good to have people like that you
know
so you don't get misguided or go on the
wrong direction
like how i like how i did at one moment
but
you gotta learn yeah i think i think
with all the fame comes a lot of money
mike what uh
what what advice would you would you
give i don't know
thinking managing money the art positive
powerful business people they don't know
how to handle money there's not to make
great deals but that
actually the art of handling money
that's an art
you know and you learn to do that and
once you
pretty much mastered that then i think
you do really good in
life financially but the art isn't trust
me
everybody the rockefeller event they got
it they spent it
and then 1913 taxes came
you know so now they're taking half your
money
so a lot of those robber barons back in
the day with vandal
and rothschild they didn't make it the
taxes blew them away they couldn't
handle the very few rubber baron
families
were less than expected like they say
more money more problems and
this is true and it's real you allow the
problem to happen only the problem if
you allow it to
be a problem even if you lose all your
money if that's the problem
you allow that to be a problem was
buying a tiger the most extravagant
thing you yeah oh no
i had plans that i had a goddamn
bunch of bunch of chateaus and stuff i
had a really
interesting life
mike how many kids do you have seven
seven kids okay
damn we need to catch up to him huh yeah
you got it
it's called let's call it the mike tyson
treaty
yeah i love i love once i have more my
wife would never do i'd love to have
more kids
how was it like because this is this is
one thing that i think about a lot man
because you know
and they everybody that i've talked to
is like hey man that's cool
congratulations man but enjoy your sleep
now
it depends on the kid really it's not
always um
hella five nights with the kids and
stuff they have their own personality
yeah you know but you know you're gonna
have to be responsible
that's something that you're not used to
loving something more than yourself
you know that's just like after that's
your time machine he's gonna go in the
future with you
so did you get up every time they cried
then um
i noticed i didn't do anything but i was
in the bed while i was crying i was
suffering too
i couldn't i couldn't sleep either she
couldn't sleep i couldn't sleep
because she she kept saying hey go to
another room go to another room
and i'll suffer with you with this no
that's nice
that's something that's probably
something i'm gonna have to uh
deal with yeah like you know you gotta
what is it uh what are they what's that
word what
what are you like your companion is
there a word out there i'm thinking of
it it's not
your wife
this meant dealing with babies are
serious man
not a joke and another joke
yes i'm looking to experience that man
how would
you having a girl too i'm having a girl
we gotta get that shotgun ready too
oh that's gonna blow
my oldest daughter she's the the first
baby i had shows a girl her name is
bella
she's 13 already and going through
different mixes
of hormones yeah trouble trouble
talking [ __ ] back to yeah
yes that's crazy now they're not like
guys like
now they like people like polo g how
would you like to end the perfect legacy
for andrew ruiz man how would you like
to leave the sport of boxing
by becoming a two-time heavyweight
champion of the world and you can do
that [ __ ] too i'm gonna sometimes buy
you a dick but you can man oh boy you
can
[Music]
yeah as long as we stay stay busy stay
ready
hit that body man your body good
hit that body come up thank you
but yeah just um becoming a champion
again
look all the things that canelo
accomplished and
no he's he's a he's a big beast you know
moving up in weights it's different from
us heavyweights that
we just stay at one stream you're gonna
be come back and be a beast in this
division
you know you could do it again you did
it once you could do it again
how many how many times would you like
to defend your title a lot of times you
know
as much as i can exactly and what i mean
do you have like a certain age when you
when you would like to retire
or is that just based on is this crazy
you say that because
before i even won the championship and
all that
um i said that i want to retire when i'm
35 years old
and you know i have four more years to
give it all i got
and to be super disciplined for those
four years to see where
where it gets me so i think 35
years old will be a perfect age and
just spend time with the family i just
think when he 35
35 is going to be so young it's gonna be
like 29.
yeah you're telling me mike i'm retired
34.
well you're 34. yeah yeah i'm 34 and i
just think
well he's been but he'll fight a couple
of years he has decided not to it wasn't
like he was getting
the ass kicked off no longer move like
how you're saying move the head more
he was fighting good he just stopped
yeah i said i want that i want that
payday mike i want i need that payday
month
can't get it by stopping and beating
people
and i get it man but when's enough
enough you know what i'm saying it's
never enough
never enough you got a baby coming out
it's never enough
why you you want to fight yeah yeah of
course
but i like a boxing match yeah
you should be calling out jake paul i
already i did
i did i don't know i don't think he
wants that smoke
was that jake paul oh [ __ ] that's no
fighter
different weight classes but of course
man i'd fight him
i just think you know i've boxed amateur
and obviously i fought my whole life in
wrestling
and all that you know what i'm saying so
anyhow but yeah go
to getting back to that it's just
different you know the promoters in
boxing and in the usc how the promotions
are different it's like you guys have
a couple promoters where you guys are
able to negotiate and get money unless
you
see fighters were under an umbrella and
they put the boss
pays what he thinks she wants to pay you
know and now i'm a two division ufc
champ olympic champ you know what i'm
saying i've accomplished a lot of my
life and
they're keeping me at the same pay dude
when the when the guys in front of me
are making millions boxing
boxing a wonderful baby [ __ ] as a world
champion i agree with you the majority
of boxers don't make money
mike you know world champion you got the
rotten out there man
yeah all you expected they know your
expenses take up so much [ __ ]
yeah you know you have to have your own
you have your own money
to promote the hand of the [ __ ]
it all depends too who you
sign with and what promoter is is giving
you those fights too
and i'm a strong believer no promoters
that's why not promotions
um we have no promoters
thanks to god i started my own promotion
company i signed up yes that's my
first fighter his name is anthony
garnika he's from oakland he fought
at the at my fight when i fought um
he's a southpaw he's a good fighter too
and
i don't know if you guys seen um
canelo's fight there's a fight before
him
he fought this asian guy his name is
soto
we we signed him too and that was like
that tall
mexican brother david bennett yeah
i grew up with them too everybody said i
hope the pressure don't get to them now
you know my guys look good that they
getting they will have to freeze i don't
think so
i think that this could happen this
kid's a different breed
but if he could be here he gets hit
because i look at him he's going to kill
him yeah check check this out mike
who spar that kid when he was 11 years
old
yeah davis yeah he was like a big chubby
kid and we were he was
he was just we're the same height as an
11 year old kid
everybody thinks he's going to give
canelo a fight
a hundred percent i think he's his
toughest threat yeah what do you think
about kayla plan and
canelo do you think kayla plant has what
it takes to
to do good against him listen
i don't know i'm not gonna be who's i
think i handle him like that i want to
see this guy been defeated everybody's
talking i saw a fighter
to him he looks pretty rugged i think um
the guy is smart i think you know i mean
canelo smart they're doing that
fast slick [ __ ] you know he's he's super
explosive
he's super compact man and he's smart
he's gonna stop kayla i think he'll stop
all
i think he'll stop everybody except
benavidez
even if he does beat benavidez like now
i think within the next
video i want to see what he could take
because he's going to get hit with some
[ __ ] i was he's tough i will see what he
can take because
he's going to put that [ __ ] on him
it's cause canelo's a counter puncher
and i think he does good with the little
people that are taller than him and
ben aviles he's really good i think he's
better than all the other guys that he's
fought but he just
covers up he stays like shield i don't
think
you know you don't like that position
yeah i don't that's not good
it's a dangerous position punches though
yeah he'll throw him from there too
though he'll he'll run up those
uppercuts left hooks
super slick and he's young he's strong
strong right he's struggling to pull
it's crazy we i've i've been owning him
since he was really young and we would
train at
freddie roach's gym i like him too i'm a
fan too
[Music]
but that's all it is is for us to get
the opportunity and for us
to you know take it and take advantage
of it
and i feel that's what he needs the
opportunity and
i'm sure i'm sure um he's gonna do good
things
he should fight one of the cholo
brothers before he fights
yeah yeah i like i like your little
brothers or that one of them
yeah the the uh the cholo yeah cholo
right charlo
oh yeah yeah
are really good too both of them both of
them are blessed
twins and they fight i better feed it i
want to see him in a real
tough one with one of those guys in the
champions league that one will sound
like he just looks like a dog
you know he looks like a dog yeah i
think ben affairs
will be do you think canelo would agree
with that do you think canelo would
say betty this is my toughest matchup
if you if that you know him no i think
canelo's gonna say
that he's gonna he's gonna beat everyone
i think he's in a
i don't think or does canelo think
that's a that's the toughest matcher
punch but canelo be moving and [ __ ] he's
not like the old point
ali mohammed ali thing like a butter you
know what i'm saying like yeah but
that's how
canelo's a box he moves he slips he's
not a typical mexican fighter
yeah he's not going to just be there to
take punches he's like an american
fighter he moves
you know yeah there's there's not a
better combination than that
you think he's pound for pound might
yeah
more so than crawford
yeah i feel he is because he's been more
active he's
he's already you know the black
community mad at you
mike i don't give a [ __ ] who's mad at me
he's the baddest [ __ ] on the
scene now yeah
there's no denying that he's stopping
people
i i also think i think it's right there
man hammer crawford i really do
i want to see crawford fight mikey
garcia yeah
you might be a good fight i don't know i
think he did
after i thought um spencer was supposed
to stop
him you know and he kept he held his own
respects
and manny pacquiao this was going to be
an exciting fight right there
yeah what do you think about that which
one spence in the
pacquiao i got pacquiao man we're just
talking about it back back there with uh
with john man
we we got a you got to go with pacquiao
because i can't i want to see somebody
beat him before i choose against him
i saw him do too many upsets he did too
many upsets for me
it's hard to go against a proven
champion like manny pacquiao man eight
division world champ
i mean the dude has beaten everybody
under the sun
you know what i'm saying i do have to
fight everybody so i think his
experience
and the fact that he's a southpaw and
he's in and now he's fights awkward
and and
first name earl spence earl spencer
and keith thurman did they fight yeah
they know
no he fought porter right yeah oh no
that's right thurman didn't fight
thurman just he just they both uh uh
garcia yeah i want to know man
it's hard to beat pacquiao tooth against
them you know
yeah you shouldn't that's that's that's
one thing he's got no older fighter
he waiting for somebody to make a
mistake he's all over the place still
you know very exciting yeah well that's
what's up man
well mike man you got any closing
thoughts here for for andy reisman any
advice yo man i think it's a possibility
if he really believes he could be
heavyweight champ again
and as you're thinking i think he should
do that he should
keep fighting good fights excited fights
to get his chance fight for the title
i'll be your entity be an awesome fight
yeah that's for a way i actually wrote
it on some piece of paper
and i s that was one of my you
keep working can you keep coming forward
jab i have to be first throwing the
combinations
and he's awkward but the head he moves
but the body doesn't move
so that's how you're saying throw the
body a lot of the body and
you good body punches too that's why you
always punch to the body
mm-hmm did it knock somebody out in the
head you got so hard punched and knocked
my
body pooped
[Laughter]
yeah well man andy it's been a pleasure
it's been an honor man congratulations
on all your success
appreciate you guys you're you're the
rocky you're that rocky story man the
guy that you know
nobody knew to had everything you know
after one fight man
we just want to you know we just wait a
little bit feel like it's over
yeah that's just the beginning that
people know andy ruiz and you know just
got to be
able to make money for your family take
care of people and stuff
that's what this is all about anyway
thank you for them
yeah yeah we'll end the third guys you
guys
thank you guys for watching this episode
of hot boxing with
mike tyson i'm your co-host triple c aka
henry cejudo
and i'm mike tyson and we're here with
andy ruiz
oh one more thing andy the world is
looking at you right here
is there anything you want to say please
they're looking at you
well just that i'm back in action i know
from my last performance
um a lot of people were a little
disappointed but
like mike tyson says yep no not too
i've been disappointed if you lost
but you know back on action baby we got
to get back to work and
on monday we're already starting to camp
so we're going to see
who's going to be next tune in we out
you